[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an action comedy film
called the shaolin boy spoilers ahead
watch out and take
care lee is a six-year-old monk studying
in the shaolin monastery he has lived in
the monastery and trained in martial
arts his entire life at the beginning of
the movie lee walks into the monastery
and apologizes to his seniors for what
he is about to do he has to showcase his
skills by fighting them without him
realizing a monk attacks him from the
side lee immediately dodges even though
the attack took him by surprise the monk
manages to throw lee to the wall but he
bounces right back and continues to
fight he showers the monk with several
kicks midair displaying his skills
moments later the first monk is defeated
when lee restrains him with a woven
bamboo basket following that he is
attacked by the second mug armed with
swords lee manages to disarm his
opponent leaving him with no choice but
to accept defeat then he approaches the
third and final monk even when
meditating the monk senses lee coming
towards him and uses a prayer bead to
perfectly hit the mirror in a way that
blinds lee then in less than a second
the kid is picked up and thrown to the
ground the monk is about to win with the
last blow but lee slides away and kicks
him in the chest the two battle and in
the end lee wins again he bows to the
shrine and walks outside while his
opponents bow to him as a sign of
respect the head monk tells lee that he
scored 88 out of 100 in the test which
is better than most students his age lee
is about to go to a new school in the
city as an exchange student during his
stay there he is supposed to live with a
family of three fathered by a great
scientist who is close to the head monk
after wishing farewell the kid leaves
for the city excited to meet new people
in the following scene we are introduced
to 15 year old feng the chief of the
taekwondo club in his school he has a
fourth grade sister shan shan who always
cheers for her older brother and loves
him dearly the manager of the school
taekwondo club is lan she analyzes
fang's matches and gives him a summary
of what he could have done better lan
also seems to have a crush on him but
denies it when asked land's brother yu
is a glutton who loves to eat more than
anything in the world the four of them
live in the same neighborhood and are
pretty close to each other one afternoon
llenn is analyzing the previous day's
taekwondo match as always while her
brother yu binges on chips and snacks
the sibling's father is a scientist
named dr han their mother died a few
years ago after which dr han has
indulged himself in his work he is
working on a special device that a group
of gangsters is interested in dr han
calls the kids to ask them how they are
doing lan is annoyed because her father
is never home with them dr han promises
to return back as soon as possible and
tells them to open a gift box that he
has just sent to the house in reality
the box contains the special device he
has created that the gang is after as
they are talking lee knocks on their
door and is received by lan she gets
busy welcoming him and doesn't notice
that her father is being abducted on the
other side of the video call the leader
of the gang larry threatens dr han to
hand them the important device dr han on
the other hand claims that there is no
such device what he has been working on
he says is an ai technology that will
allow his kids to talk to an ai with
their mother's voice i wonder if she'll
be good at narrating recap videos the
leader doesn't believe him and holds him
hostage on checking the cctv camera
footage he finds out that the device has
been shipped to his home and received by
his children two of larry's henchmen
sloppy and fist volunteer to retrieve
the device no matter what until they get
a hold of it dr han will be kept hostage
sloppy and fist are excited because this
is their first job as gangsters they
dress up in eccentric clothes as a
disguise and arrive in front of land's
house sloppy tries to barge in when it
gets dark but fist suggests they wait
until the kids leave for school the next
day meanwhile lee is getting accustomed
to the new environment he sees lan
watching a taekwondo match on tv and is
fascinated by the sport later he tries
to do his daily nighttime meditation
while you plays a video game both of
them disturb each other and find it hard
to live together but soon they play the
video game together and bond over it
case closed video games are better than
meditation in her room lan opens that
box sent by her father and sees a panda
keychain inside what she doesn't know is
that it also holds a pen drive that the
gang is looking for on pressing a button
the panda asks lan to set a voice
activated password she exclaims what
password which is set as the new
password without her knowing on testing
it further she realizes that the panda
is an ai that has her mother's voice the
next morning lee gets ready for his
first day of school alongside you and
lan sloppy and fist watch them from
inside their car planning to break in
right after they are out of sight but
just then sloppy notices that lan has
hung the panda keychain on her bag they
change plans and decide to steal it from
her on the way to school the group meets
feng and his sister shan shan llan
introduces them to lee as they're
talking sloppy swiftly snatches the
keyring and walks away lee notices this
and does a high jump and several
backflips to get to him feng is
impressed to see that he is a skilled
fighter they both beat him up and get
the panda back but sloppy doesn't give
up he snatches it yet again not learning
his lesson from the first time the kids
soon surround him and trap him in a
garbage bin before pushing him down the
road at school lee is introduced to his
classmates who are amazed to see a child
monk for the first time they ask him
questions like if he can ever get
married and if he knows kung fu the
teacher quiets them down and asks them
to wait for the gym period to see his
kung fu skills during the gym class the
coach informs them of a fitness test
that will be held next month the ones
who do not pass the test will have to
repeat the class next year as well you
is worried because he is out of shape
and can barely walk properly their first
task is to run a hundred meters a
trained lee completes two laps before
his classmates can complete even one
next they are asked to do push-ups one
of the many specialties that lee has he
does more than a hundred while the other
kids can hardly do two to show his true
capabilities he even does push-ups with
a single hand and then with his body
vertical what a show-off this kid is
basically goku everyone cheers and
praises him then it is time for them to
do high jumps elementary school high
jumps are a piece of cake for lee
however you struggles and falls face
down on the platform back in dr han's
lab the gangster larry has tied him to a
chair and is hitting him with golf balls
to keep himself entertained dr han
teaches him new techniques at his own
expense at night sloppy and fist break
into the house looking for the panda lee
sees them and hides behind a stuffed toy
to scare them he troubles the rookie
gangsters but they soon see him and try
to fight him when lan comes downstairs
the gangsters grab the panda and run
away lee tells them what happened but
the siblings think he is joking in the
following scene sloppy and fest are at
the lab with golf balls in their mouths
it turns out that they accidentally
stole a panda humidifier instead of the
special device they're putting goddamn
pandas on everything these days larry
has to sell the said device to his
clients in three days which makes him
impatient he uses fist and sloppy as
golf tees to threaten them to complete
the task quicker the following day after
school the group is watching fang fight
against an opponent you and shan chan
are talking about two ugly girls in the
back of the bleachers it turns out that
the said girls are sloppy and fist in
disguise they eye the panda on land's
bag and wait for the right time to
retrieve it just then lee challenges
fang to a match and everyone goes to the
front to watch it behind them the thugs
try to take off the panda from the bag
but their wig gets stuck making them
struggle as the intense fight continues
we see that fang and the lead match in
skills it ends abruptly when both
participants refuse to hit each other
just then everyone turns around and sees
sloppy and fist in their schoolgirl
dresses the kids attack the gangsters
but the two managed to flee with the
panda after taking a girl hostage the
students go to the principal and call
the police who promised to do their best
to find them lee blames himself for what
happened because if he hadn't challenged
feng to a fight lan wouldn't have been
distracted the rest of the group makes
him understand that they do not blame
him larry finally gets the panda and
uses the pen drive inside of it to open
a program on a computer however it
requires a password to be accessed larry
asks dr han what the password is but he
refuses to tell them a couple of
programmers try to break the code but
even after trying for an entire day they
are unsuccessful by the end of it larry
starts to lose his mind and has a mental
breakdown then he sees land's message on
dr han's phone and decides to use her to
blackmail him lan has asked her father
to come to her birthday tomorrow larry
replies as dr han and claims that he
will be there on time the next evening
lan and her friends gather at her house
for the birthday party meanwhile feng yu
li and shan chan have gone to the market
to get her presents lan gets a message
from her father saying that he is
outside however on going out to check
she is abducted and put inside a van at
the same time lee and the group spot her
and follow the van on their bicycles
they reach dr han's lab and start
looking for her larry and his business
partner are under stress because they
were supposed to close the deal
yesterday to make the process quicker
larry puts a knife to lan's face and
asks her about the password she in turn
inquires what password and it opens the
program on the computer outside sloppy
and fist are guarding the place lee and
fang attack them and knock them out in
no time however they are soon confronted
by larry's right-hand man bradley he is
a fighter hence they struggle to defeat
him even when teamed up inside the lab
larry and his partner are about to seal
the deal but just then eu arrives and
secretly frees his sister and father lee
also comes to their aid and helps them
fight the gangsters amidst the chaos
larry gets a hold of the suitcase with
the pen drive and runs outside he is
stopped by dr han you and lan who all
beat him up in the meantime lee joins
fang again to fight against bradley
initially they struggle but they
eventually manage to defeat him at last
the police arrive at the scene and save
the day in the ending scene we see the
school's principal award lee and you for
their bravery subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching